[Music]
over here right right over here down
here
welcome to ios 14. you can do this too
shrink down a video or a facetime call
in the new iphone operating system
you just need to know where to find a
hidden setting and that's really the
story of this year's ios release
it's packed with fairly obscure features
that are very useful
and that fixed problems you probably
didn't even realize were problems
i've uncovered 14 of the best features
14 because you know ios
number one widgets you can now add these
little widgets with glanceable live info
about the weather news you name it right
to your home screen
sure this is pretty much a direct
android ripoff but apple did a nicer job
only took 12 years there are two ways to
add them
hold down on the home screen when
everything starts to jiggle
tap the plus button in the upper left
and pick your favorite widget
i'm super into the battery percentage
one and if you want to be depressed at a
glance try adding the new dynamic screen
time widget which shows you how long
you've been on your device
another way to add swipe left to right
on the home screen to the widget screen
hold down on the one you want and drag
away
number two smart stacks or what i call
mega widgets you can combine a few
widgets into one
and scroll through them or have them
auto rotate
go back to the widget page scroll down
and tap smart stack
after you add one hold down on the
widget and customize
swipe to delete certain widgets and hold
down to reorder
another way to make stacks just drag
widgets on top of each other
number three app library you know what's
annoying
this okay oculus should
no i want to move it no i want to go to
this page
organizing apps into folders now apple
does that for you
swipe to your last page of apps then
swipe one more time
and you'll see the new app library this
places all your apps into automatically
generated categories
search for your apps up here
or pull down to get a long list of your
apps number four
hide app pages hold down on the home
screen
then tap these little dots and you can
select which app pages you'd like to
hide
in case you're wondering how i've set up
my home screen i've got my most used
apps on the main home screen
and then this stacked widget up here and
that's it
i just swipe to the app library when i
need apps no more pages
you still with me we're moving on now to
messages
number five pinned conversations can't
find your family group chat or another
super important messaging chain
tap edit in the upper left then edit
pins hit the little pin next to the
messages to pin it
number six threaded replies in a long
messaging chain
reply to a specific message long press
on the message
and select reply to be honest this isn't
all that well implemented
it's hard to see where the replies
actually are
number seven emoji search yep
don't really need to explain this one
halfway mark grab a snack gatorade
we're gonna get through this number
eight picture and picture
you know how when you're on a facetime
call and you swipe up and the video just
pauses and goes away
well no more here i am always with you
while you're distracted and doing
something else ios has a picture in
picture mode so you can just keep the
video and conversation going
just swipe up on the facetime app during
a call
and now just like ipads
picture-in-picture also works with other
videos
other apps will need to add support but
in safari here's how it works
go into full screen mode when viewing a
video then tap the picture and picture
button
you can move the box around and also
hide it
number nine facetime eye contact you
know how when you're video calling you
look at the screen and not the camera
because it's more natural
well apple's using machine learning to
make it look to the other caller like
you're looking at the camera
go to settings facetime scroll down and
switch on
eye contact it sort of works
number 10 safari privacy report there
are lots of obvious privacy features
like this new little green dot that
appears whenever your camera is being
used
but one feature that you'll have to seek
out is in safari
tap the small a's up here then privacy
report
here you'll see all the trackers that
are following you across the web
number 11 approximate location this is
one of the best new privacy features
instead of giving an app your exact
location which can often reveal your
home address
you can now share your approximate
location with any app that requests your
location data
go to settings privacy
then location and switch off precise
location on the apps where you'd like to
limit this
number 12 sleep mode in the health app
set up sleep mode so your device sleeps
when you do
you can set up sleep first set your
sleep hours
then you can enable sleep mode which
will turn on do not disturb and disable
notifications
from lighting up your home screen the
entire screen just goes to sleep till
you tell it to wake up
number 13 back tap this is a bit of a
crazy one
when i tap the back of my iphone two
times now it takes a screenshot
you can customize two or three tap
actions to do what you'd like including
screenshots or launching control center
go to settings accessibility
touch back tap
and then double tap from there you can
pick from a list of shortcuts
this only works with the iphone 8 and
later though number 13
different defaults finally you can
change your default mail or email app
in settings scroll down to a browser app
like chrome or microsoft edge
select it and then select default
browser app now when you tap a link
anywhere in the operating system
it should launch in that browser
[Music]
we did it we made it through all the
tips what are you still doing here
go make a mega widget or put a mask on
your memoji oh yeah that's another thing
you can do in ios 14.
oh crap now i've given you 15 tips come
on get out of here let's go